this week on brian ross investigates
preparing for war
new videos show russian troops preparing
for battle near the ukrainian border
what a russian invasion of the ukraine
means for americans a stark warning of a
possible cyber war that would directly
affect american websites disrupting
utilities businesses and government
former u.s cyber czar richard clark is
here with the latest
two or three steps down the road we
could be
in a cyber war with russia
plus the epidemic of rage
why are so many people losing their cool
acting out their frustrations and anger
challenging authority as the covet
pandemic blues just won't go away there
is a little bit
less sense of that there is somebody in
charge that there is somebody who's
going to sort of
stand the limit and this week's winners
and losers in the media see if you agree
with the choices made by the editors of
mediaite
what you see on dr fauci this is what
people say to me that he doesn't
represent science to them he represents
joseph mengele
from the studios of the law and crime
trial devil in new york city's herald
square
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to those of you watching
us on facebook live i'm brian ross
joined as always tonight by my colleague
rhonda schwartz and rhonda we begin with
warnings for americans about a possible
cyber war with russia
the conflict in the ukraine may feel
like it's a long way off but a top
expert is telling us tonight it would
not take much for it to spread quickly
on the internet to the united states
rhonda
that's right brian tensions are high on
the border between ukraine and russia
where the russians have massed tens of
thousands of troops and key pieces of
military equipment president biden is
predicting an invasion and they appear
to be on a war footing brian
and we're joined now by richard clark
long-time adviser to presidents on
national security the country's first
cyber czar mr clark if the invasion
takes place uh in ukraine we have a
sense that it's a far away it won't
affect americans but that's not exactly
true is it
no i think it will affect americans you
know last time
the russians attacked ukraine in
cyberspace
which was about four years ago
they destroyed
the hardware
that runs most companies
and
that attack got out of the country
by mistake and it did billions of
dollars of damage in the us and europe
so what about in the united states are
we vulnerable if russia should try to do
something in ukraine would it extend to
our uh our homeland well it could by
mistake as it did four years ago but it
could also do so intentionally because
this is not a one move game
this is a move counter move counter move
so if you think three steps ahead
let's say they invade we will then
impose very draconian sanctions on them
they're already written they're on the
president's desk he has only to sign
them everybody's ready to implement them
we've even told the russians what they
are
and the russians in response have said
if you do that
we will do something drastic
so what could the drastic be
the drastic could be
intentional cyber attacks
on u.s infrastructure
you know the russians
on two occasions attacked ukraine's
electric power grid and shut the power
off by cyber attacks there's reason to
believe they could do that in parts of
the united states
the thing that microsoft found over the
weekend
was that russia was going into ukrainian
companies
and wiping all the software
so there's no software so the the
computers are just door stops
uh that could happen here too
so what i've been advising is that
companies need to think about
uh all they can do
to increase their security in the weeks
ahead
in cyberspace because
two or three steps down the road we
could be
in a cyber war with russia
and how would we respond to that if we
got into a as you say step after step
cyber war
well it's not clear who would suffer
more and i guess that's not really the
issue we would suffer
they could too but that doesn't help us
we would suffer uh if our power grids
went out here and there
if key infrastructure wasn't operating
if companies lost all their software and
their maybe the attack even gets into
their backup systems
think of it as ransomware only without
the ransom
ransomware on a grand scale
across the united states
we've never had a cyber war like that
and i i don't think i'm being hyperbolic
we know the russians can do it we know
that they have said
if we do the sanctions
they will do something drastic i don't
think they're going to do anything
militarily against us that would be
folly
so what else is left well what else is
left is cyber war
and so you see we're on the brink really
of a potential first cyber war
i think so
uh now we don't really know what putin's
plan is i think only putin knows and he
may not have made up his mind yet
what he's doing is everything that he
needs to do
to invade ukraine
he's done let's say hypothetically there
are 20 steps that you need to do if
you're the russian military uh he's done
17 18 of them uh and so as jen saki the
white house press secretary was saying
this week and tony blinken was saying
this week
the attack could now come at any time
because the amount of time that it takes
to do the remaining steps
and then invade is so short
that we wouldn't have warning we
we have warning now we're not going to
get any more
you don't like to give odds but what do
you think are the prospects for a
diplomatic resolution
i don't i don't give odds you know i
used to be in the intelligence business
and i was always asked by
policymakers uh what are the odds of
this what are the odds of that
and i went back historically and looked
what we had answered in the past we're
always wrong
what i what i say instead is rather than
giving you the odds i say
what's in the way of it happening
uh
are there impediments to a certain thing
happening uh and how difficult would it
be to overcome those impediments
uh we could have a diplomatic settlement
sure if the russians wanted it
but they'd have to eat a lot of crow
because they made demands diplomatic
demands that they know nato can't give
them
they demanded that nato never admit any
other organization any other nation into
the into the organization
sweden wants to get in finland wants to
get in
they know that might happen certainly
going to happen before ukraine the
interesting thing is he demanded putin
demanded that we not let ukraine in
nato was never going to do that i mean
it really wasn't on the table this is a
made-up crisis
so for a diplomatic settlement
you could put all sorts of fig leaves on
it but basically
putin would not get uh nine out of the
ten things he's demanded
worst case if it begins there is an
invasion and the sanctions and the back
and forth begins what's the exit ramp
what's the off ramp to end it
well so there are two scenarios people
are talking about one is he invades and
takes over the whole country motivated
by a desire to recreate the soviet union
uh if he does that the price is very
high because there'll be a guerrilla war
the ukrainian's not going to roll over
they'll do kind of what the iraqis did
when the americans charged up to baghdad
they'll hold for a while they'll fight
for a while conventionally and then
they'll disappear into the countryside
and fight a guerrilla war that could be
very very costly especially if we help
the guerrillas
as we did when the russian army invaded
afghanistan
we
gave arms and assistance to the fighters
in afghanistan if you remember way back
in the 80s
and it was so bad the russians pulled
out
we could make that happen again
that's scenario one
less likely scenario two is he grabs a
piece here and a piece there
right now he has a geography problem
he's already grabbed a piece of land in
the black sea called crimea and there's
no land connection from russia to it
so what he might do is grab a piece of
ukraine about a hundred miles wide so
that he has a land connection to crimea
he might grab that he might grab
something in the north uh
and he might try a military uh
related coup to overthrow the government
in ukraine
but i think those are much more likely
steps
than having him swallow the whole
country
all right richard clark thank you so
much for being with us tonight as always
excellent insight into what's happening
overseas thank you brian
up next an epidemic of rage in this
country americans losing their cool as
kovalev 19 takes its toll on our
civility you're watching brian ross
investigates of the law and crime trial
network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
we turn now to what appears to be an
epidemic of rage in this country with
leading mental health experts saying we
are seeing yet another one of the
symptoms of coven 19.
this morning fallout growing from this
disturbing flight fight ending in a
passenger being wrapped in tape
it's life back in the sky
if we don't stand up it's only going to
get worse unruly passengers
bizarre
incidents all taking place inside planes
[Music]
cell phone video captured this unruly
customer refusing to follow the local
rules to wear a mask at the kabuki
restaurant in woodland hills
[Applause]
a violent altercation at a mcdonald's in
indiana a customer spitting on a hostess
in san jose even a brazen dine and dash
attempt in new jersey we're seeing it
across the country unruly customers
acting out and restaurant workers say
they're fed up
to get a better understanding of what's
going on we're joined by karen mosk a
psychologist who works outside
washington dc and karen what's behind
this epidemic of rage
there is uh a general uh sense of loss
of control i think definitely since the
uh pandemic
people
feel like things are not getting back to
normal even when we sort of
loosened up a little bit in the fall
things aren't really the same as they
were
schools aren't the same travel isn't the
same shopping experiences aren't the
same and because there's so many these
these sort of small and subtle
differences people are frustrated and
they feel like they don't have a sense
of control over their lives like they
did prior
not everyone's getting violent why are
those who are expressing their rage with
violence why are they acting that way
i think that's a good question
and i think that that we don't really
know the answer definitively um
i do think there is
a general
shift in
the way people
trust one another i think that there is
a general mistrust of authority um
and so
it in the past when people were sort of
comfortable with the manager or the
person at the front desk or the
principal of the school um they sort of
believed that that those people in
authority had your best interest at
heart all of a sudden um they don't
believe that anymore and i think that
the more skeptical a person is
the more
doubtful the person is in um
in authority i think they
you know
get more frustrated and more rageful and
what do you tell your clients who have
these kinds of issues how do they
control themselves how do they handle
this when people are experiencing
intense emotion there are internalizing
problems like depression or anxiety and
then there are externalizing problems
like anger and rage when we're talking
about rage we're talking about people
who
lose control of their emotions they're
sort of
putting them on to others in their
environment so the bad feelings that
they're having are other people's fault
and are because of what other people are
doing to them versus sort of
internalizing the issue and making it
about them
and yet there have been warnings from
law enforcement they're going to go
after those who act out on airplanes or
restaurants that this continues though
even so
they don't fear the law
i think there is a little bit
less sense of that there is somebody in
charge that there is somebody who's
going to sort of
stand the limit and so yes
um authorities are called on airplanes
um
but i don't
i don't
think that people are putting their
trust into into leaders right now and to
what extent do you see this rage factor
essentially amplified on social media at
certain broadcast outlets
i think um one of the the unique
aspects of the times we're living in
is that everybody has a video
capability on their phone and when there
is any sort of confrontation at all if
you look around you see that everybody
is
videotaping it on their phones
and
i think this amplifies the problem and
makes it seem so much more
of a common issue than than it might
even be
um we every time there's a big blow up
or every time somebody loses their cool
there is video recording of it and it is
put on tick tock or
another platform and for everybody else
to see
so what do you tell people about how to
keep their cool
it's a good question um
we have to talk about why emotions are
so intense right now and the best thing
to do before
you
understand how to keep your cool is to
understand why you're feeling the
frustration you're feeling to begin with
i think um
people depersonalize others right now um
rather than understanding that
everybody's just trying to do their best
and
taking time to understand when your
feelings are getting ramped up so it
doesn't go
automatically you sort of overheat if
you start feeling frustrated if you
start feeling
um
worried or out of control
then you know you have to remove
yourself from a situation
take time take deep breaths and
basically recalibrate
and keep your cool karen moss thank you
so much for being with us here tonight
you're welcome thank you for having me
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media see what the editors of
media had had to say about fox news
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin the editor-in-chief of
meteorite which like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media group and aiden you've chosen as a
winner this week fox news now given all
the rants and misinformation why are
they a winner
that's right so putting aside all the
criticisms of fox news that we've made
on this on this segment repeatedly and
putting aside what you think of the
network's politics it goes without
saying that fox news is the most watched
thing on cable news uh it draws an
audience that is far bigger than msnbc
and cnn often far bigger than msnbc and
cnn combined um that has been the case
this week
on friday which is typically a pretty
soft day for cable news networks no show
on fox news drew less
than a million viewers
which is a sizable audience uh cnn and
msnbc were far behind cnn didn't even
draw uh more than 700 000 viewers for
any single show
even their top-rated shows um so it was
really a strong ratings week for fox
news
and that comes at a time when all of
cable news audiences are down so the fox
the fact that fox is still pulling in a
really sizable audience is a sign of
their influence uh and their continued
success and suggests they're just
shrugging off the criticism because it
works
right i mean i think fox news that's
been their play uh since its inception
um you know no matter how many times uh
the new york times op-ed page uh runs a
lengthy piece criticizing uh fox news um
as a danger to democracy uh viewers
continue to tune in um and are in fact
probably spurred by that um so i think
fox news sees the prophets continuing to
to come in and the audience continuing
to be there uh and they really don't
care about any of that criticism a lot
of times that criticism is justified um
so you know i wouldn't say that that's
necessarily a good thing but the
audience continues to tune in
and for this week's loser you've chosen
the former cbs 60 minutes correspondent
laura logan who hasn't been seen much on
the air since she made these comments
about dr faki on fox
what you see on dr fauci this is what
people say to me that he doesn't
represent science to them he represents
joseph mengele dr joseph
the doc the nazi doctor who did
experiments on jews during the second
world war and in the concentration camps
and so she has disappeared from the
airwaves since that
right uh this is a good example of what
is being aired on fox news not being
worthy of a win uh despite uh the
audience still being there uh laura
logan uh was once revered journalist for
60 minutes
um she took to appearing on fox news a
lot lately in the last year uh and
pushed a series of conspiracy theories
what you saw there was her comparing dr
anthony fauci to an infamous nazi doctor
of joseph mengele after those comments
which prompted a lot of outrage uh
criticism and calls for her firing she
disappeared from the air at fox news now
she was never employed by fox but she
appeared frequently as an unpaid guest
on the network and actually hosted
documentary show on fox nation now she
hasn't appeared on fox news since uh we
reported on mediaite uh on monday that
she had also been dropped by her
longtime agent uh who was at united
talent agency or uta so not only is she
no longer appearing on fox news she's
also been dropped by her agency which is
a pretty big deal for any journalist and
means that it's going to be hard to see
where lar logan is going to be able to
get her news out now um that she's
basically fully independent and has no
representation i doubt any you know the
traditional networks are going to be
hosting her uh fox news certainly has
signaled that they're not going to be
hosting her anymore on their airwaves um
so yeah i mean it's a serious loss for
for you know a once revered journalist
and a a stunning fall from grace and
from prestige
right i mean laura logan was you know
was a very very prestigious journalist
when she was at 60 minutes and you know
it was a bit of a long time coming
she made a series of controversial
comments on fox news this was just the
latest and the most controversial that
got her kicked off well hey mclaughlin
thank you so much for being with us
tonight as always your picks of the
winners and losers and thanks to all of
you for watching us we'll see you back
here again next week on the law and
crime trial network
[Music]
you